uh and about covid and the vaccine the
US Army is sending letters and I I sent
rob a photo to former troops saying that
in light of the removal of the covid-19
vaccine requirement they uh cannot apply
to to get their reasons of discharge
change this means derogatory remarks or
dishonorable discharges can now be
removed or reversed notice notice how
how weird that is right they're also
inviting unvaccinated uh people to join
because recruitment numbers are down so
all of a sudden they stop their vaccine
requirements right but not before
forcing thousands of soldiers to get the
JB P just like our friend Pat major
Katie Hernandez she's a really good a
friend of our she's on my podcast she
now suffers from myocarditis okay now
those soldiers should be able to Sue and
that's the letter that Rob uh has up
right now and it's like Pat all this
like you just nailed it she should get
her VA benefits so she doesn't go broke
on that I think 100% she just she she
just got stationed uh somewhere else she
was here on the show but it's like not
really now you're telling them like Hey
listen that dishonorable discharge that
mind you and Pat you know this it ruins
your life Adam if you have dishonorable
discharge at on your record that is
nobody's looking at you bro that means
the government doesn't trust you so now
what you're going to reverse it now
after you've already ruined my life F
you to the government for doing that
type of to these people and and
speaking of P I'm going to stand the
vaccine uh uh vaccine topic while I was
going down this Rabbit Hole I started
seeing videos and some of these articles
about something that you never hear
about it's the Amish community uh when
it comes to the unvaccinated like their
their children cuz our our numbers for
for autism and add and all these chronic
illnesses are sky rcking in the Amish
community the percentage of their
children having all these diseases atam
is very very low almost even
non-existent and it's like our
government our government has been
studying the Amish people for decades
Tom but you know why none of these come
out to the public cuzz it would destroy
the CDC and all their narratives about
forcing all these drugs on our kids it's
crazy that you never we you think of
Amish and people are like look at those
weird look at those weirdos but you know
what those weirdos as children are not
dealing with the that our kids are
dealing with because they haven't been
forced all this poison narratives hate
sustained data set perfect segue to my
point and um look um am I trying to go
Amish on you no but listen one of the
great honors of being on this podcast
since pbd started this in 2020 is
learning right I've been wrong on some
things I've been right on some things
but I've learned a lot and one of the
biggest things that I've learned uh is
the the need for traditional family
values in America okay the the nuclear
family a two- parent household and
understanding what makes the world work
and what makes relationships work and
what raises kids the right way and
watching how Pat Raised his kids and
watching how Tom raised his kids like
Vinnie you and I we've been pretty
selfish right you've been focused on
your stand-up comedy career I've focused
on making money doing everything with
that partying in South Beach but you
know there comes of time in a man life
whether he's 30 40 50 whatever the
freaking number where you realize all
right there's more to life than just
having a good time and partying and
telling jokes and all that and I do want
a family one day you know I'm dealing
with some different women out there I
get it we're honing in trans women or
just just regular old old school women
got you but i i i i i all my best
friends are married 99% of them I assume
most of your best I'm Uncle Adam to all
these kids I have a nephew like I I want
to have a family and it scares the hell
out of me to see that this is what
parents have to worry about these lgbtq
Y A Plus woke transgender this is what
kids are being indoctrinated with and
it's scary as hell and injected with and
injected with as well of course forcing
forcing something inside of them so you
know you famously I quote it all the
time whether someone should be selfish
or selfless and for if you're a young
person out there and you don't have a
family you don't have kids you should be
mostly selfish make your money do your
thing look your best feel your best act
your best but once you have you're
married and have kids you have to be way
more selfless right 100% And it's just
very scary to see what's going on out
there and uh I understand why parents
are freaking out and I understand why
this is such a hot button issue I would
not want my kid dealing with the
nonsense that's going on today I'm glad
these service people are going to get
some relief cuz normally a U-turn like
this from government only happens an
election year and at least it's not oh
oh wait oh wait yeah but so Pat being
because this is an article of of the
army you were in the Army how do you
feel that they're doing this now to
these PE to these thousands of people
Pat you were in I was in how how do you
respond to something like that you're
getting a letter now saying hey what my
bad Rob go back to that ad the the one
that says no vaccines to join the
military whatever ad you had zoom in a
little bit this is what the recruitments
are putting out exactly so look at this
US Army covid vaccine not required
career opportunities over 150 jobs up to
$50,000 of establishment enlistment
bonus full-time part-time guaranteed uh
uh 1918 pay per month starting for
officers 3637 over $70,000 for college
4,000 in tuition assistant guaranteed
job for choice no 23 4 5 six year uh uh
enlistment options 100% College tuition
travel the world 30 days paid ation army
training and course uh count towards
your college degree so can you imagine
how embarrassing it is to not have to
say vaccine is not required the lead
story you now they say don't bury the
lead that's the number one thing by the
US Army embarrassing that they have to
say some like this
now for them to call back the other guys
and say hey come back this happens that
part is normal Elon Musk fired 50% of
the company and then he realized oh
we fired some of the people we needed
yeah and they're like listen can you
come back I we need you can you come
back and some of them came back someone
said screw you I'm not coming back this
happens everywhere um the Army made a
mistake the military made a mistake and
it the the people that were forced out
and were publicly humiliated we had a
guy on here that was forced out after 14
years and we had him talking two years
ago how he felt what he was feeling like
it was emotional this is all you know
you want to do 20 30 years in the middle
if you had 14 years you know what you
want to do six more years to get your
retirement you're trying to get your 20-
year retirement you're trying to get to
your 25 30 year retirement but uh I'm
not surprised bad ideas keep getting
exposed it's continuous the only thing I
ask is we need accountability and for
people to not have a short memory when
they try to do this again that's the
biggest part again the next time be loud
you saw what they did don't sit on the
sidelines and say you should take it if
you don't take it you don't care about
the elderly people you don't care about
your parents and your grandparents what
if your grandma died what if your mom
died what if you this Di and they would
put this fear in everybody and uh it was
a very weird time so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here